hello everyone and welcome to one of the
greatest games that you will ever see it
was played in 2015 it was the singfield
cup and it is Wesley Seoul versus Hikaru
Nakamura singfield cup was back then a
part of the grand chest story with the
second event and the nine regular
players Hikaru being one of them were
joined by the wild card for this
tournament it was Wesley's soul and we
are going to discuss the the standings
after the game and uh a little bit about
the tournament but what is important is
that if Hikaru did not have his Immortal
game against Bodie's girlfriend that was
played a year before this it was played
in 2014 in the world team championship
in abusa in Turkey this one would have a
great chance of being considered for
hikaru's Immortal game it is just that
good I'm not kidding it's it's truly one
of the greatest game that you will ever
see and it you will also see just what
happens when you challenge Hikaru to
show what he can do in his King's Indian
defense is just completely out of this
world so that being said let's check it
out West Wesley has the white pieces and
he opens with D4 Hikaru plays Knight to
F6 with C for G6 going for the king's
Indian defense Knight the C3 Bishop to
G7 and E4 we have Pawn to D6 and Knight
to F3 Hikaru castles we have Bishop to
E2 and pawn to E5 so all very standard
stuff this is the so-called Orthodox
variation of the king's Indian uh
castles and now Knight to C6 all top
moves uh nothing new being played here
D5 Knight D7 and in the game uh that he
carplayed against Bodie's girlfriend in
2014 Golf and golf and continued with
Knight to D2 if you haven't seen it uh
even pause this video now check out the
first link in the description below
watch that video first that is the The
hikaru's Immortal game it's a bit of an
older video but you know the the moves
are still the same and you can see
Meadow chilling in the background and
for those of you who are wondering where
is metal wise he no longer behind me he
is a bit older but he's still very much
alive and we are having a good time
every day but he just doesn't enjoy
walking up the stairs at that much so
while he might still visit us is just
not as often uh so but yeah he's doing
very well but yeah here we have knighted
the E1 bit of a different approach by
Wesley and now at night to D7 the the
idea is pretty standard
uh you want to start pushing those King
side pawns and it's something that you
will see pretty much in every King's
Indian game black plays on the king side
black goes for King side attack while
white will try to organize a minority
attack on the queen side so here uh well
there are some other moves that are more
popular today maybe like Bishop T3 or
Knight to D3 here we have Pawn to F3 and
now Pawn to F5 by Hikaru very nicely
done Bishop T3 and pawn to F4 so again
nothing new here many many games in the
database even in those days Bishop to F2
Pawn to G5 Hikaru continues his attack
now he wants to play of course H5 G4 put
the knights back to G6 and F6 and go for
that white king and G1 we have Knight to
D3 and now Knight to G6 doesn't really
matter some someone plays Knight to F6
for someone plays Knight to G6 for
sikaru obviously prefers this line uh we
have Pawn to C5 Wesley continues with
his Pawn storm on the queen side and
Knight to F6 we have rooked the C1 and
now Rook to F7 basically it looks like
like a white and black are ignoring each
other one is playing on the king side
one on the queen side but that's just
how this line is played with King to H1
and now uh we have Pawn to H5 by hikar
which is very interesting uh later on in
2018 Hikaru played this exact same uh
position against Alexander Linderman in
the U.S Championship 2018 and he
continued with Bishop to f8 and while
both Bishop to f8 and H5 are the top
engine moves uh the engine prefers Pawn
to H5 a bit more but probably Hikaru
thought okay of course Alexander knows
my game against Wesley he's not gonna
fall for the exact same thing so he
probably decided to mix it up a little
bit but okay here he continues with H5
and now there are a couple of games that
reach this position and I will tell you
what was played and what should have
been played sort of Wesley played C
count for Sunday six and it was then
after move 17 that this position has
never been repeated again or uh back
when they played the game a new position
has been but how you should continue
this game is probably something like
Knight B5 you allow G4 then you play C
captures on D60 captures you capture on
A7 but it's really complicated like look
at this Pawn to G3 you will play Rook
captures on C8 and after Rook captures
and create the Knight captures on C8 you
will play G captures on F2 and not after
the Knight moves you don't want to give
up the Knight as well Queen to A5 now
you have to find this Knight to B5 move
so okay I mean if you don't know all of
this you're probably not gonna find it
over the board regardless of um uh the
time control and after Queen captures on
B5 of course now you unleash uh the the
bishop uh you unleash the Bish I don't
know if anyone ever said that uh who
knows Knight captures on E5 attacks the
queen uh Queen captures on B2 and now
Knight captures and G6 picking up the
Knight here and you know it's a game
still being played uh well it's a bit
weird for white but still nothing uh not
no danger there uh but okay after H5 uh
Wesley continued with the c captures and
D6 move and we have a completely new
game so C capture some D6 we have
Knights to B5 and now Pawn to A6 chases
away the Knight Knight the A3 you could
also go back to C3 but that kind of
defeats the purpose of choosing this
line fonta B5 now Hikaru does grab more
space here and he gives up the C6 Square
for The Rook but uh yeah Hikaru doesn't
mind we have a rook to C6 by Wesley and
now you don't really want to kick away
The Rook with something like uh Bishop
to B7 because the bishop is much more
useful on this dagger not in here he
cargo we just moved the rook and this
bishop would be pointless here so if
anything you want to put it on D7 you
can't right now because then you would
blunder the D6 Pawn so here just G4 we
have Queen to C2 doubling up preparing
to Triple up on the C file and now Queen
to f8 Preparing Bishop to D7 now the D6
Pawn is defended by the queen uh Rook to
C1 westly nicely tripling up on the C
file and Bishop to D7 even allowing Rook
to C7 but as you'll see uh even though
Wesley has full control over the C file
and he has a rook on the seventh rank uh
the The Rook officially becomes a pig
there's not much to do there Bishop to
H6 the bishop will be useful here later
on Hikaru even has some ideas of playing
Bishop G5 and Bishop to d8 to kick away
The Rook from C7 he that's just how much
uh he knows these positions of the
king's Indian uh Bishop to E1 and now
Ponte H4 and now it's hard to decide do
you allow the advancement of the pawn or
or do you capture on G4 Wesley captured
because it's really really hard to allow
the spawn to advance point is that if
you play King to G1 yes you can
completely blockade the position
uh it's just that it will be that much
easier for black to play this and it's
not going to be hard to remove this uh
Rook Queen Rook battery imagine
something like Queen to B8 and now after
let's say Bishop to A5 you will play
Knights the E8 you kick away the rook
and the ones The Rook moves now you play
Bishop G5 you uh put the bishop here you
trade off the bishop for Bishop let's
say King to H1 You're Gonna Play Bishop
to d8 and even if the trade happens okay
cappers captors but uh the point is that
uh all the all the exchanges here all
the trades of the pieces favor Black
because if we imagine everything gets
traded off the board maybe they're a
knight and the bishop remain white will
always have this problem of let's say
Bishop captures on H3 you're not going
to be able to activate your king your
king will be stuck there on H1 G1 for
the rest of the game because if you try
to move it and of course black will uh
you know shift the game over to the
queen side he will try to grab some of
these pawns maybe try to advance his own
pawns the problem will be Bishop
captures and H3 will remain a threat for
the rest of of the game and then G
captures then G Pawn becomes a pawn so
it's not the end game you want to play
but it could be it could very well be
White's best hope here but with the
played F captures on G4 and here uh
Hikaru just unleashes uh spectacular
attack one that uh well uh it's uh it's
been a while since we've seen an attack
like this in a classical game Hikaru
plays Pawn to F3 and okay I mean you
open up an attack towards the bush The
Rook here but Wesley says uh my position
isn't all that great I would very much
enjoy giving up the exchange for these
two pawns so he just captures it g
captures an F3 but now Hikaru does not
take the rookie card plays uh Knight
captures on e4 and I thought about
asking you to pause the video to find
this move but there's even a nicer one
that I will ask you to find because here
we will check out what happens if uh if
the Knight is captured which is the
movie you should not play we're gonna
check out what happens if you find the
absolute best move and we are going to
to discuss what happens after the move
that Wesley actually played so can you
capture the Knight no no you most
certainly cannot if you capture the
Knight it then comes Rook the F1 with
check and you cannot capture if you
capture then Queen captures an F1 is
Checkmate so what can you do you have to
play King to G2 and now comes the bishop
to E3 it's actually similar to what
happened in the game only a few moves
down the road the thread of course now
is Rook to G1 so how do you stop this
you have to trade Rooks Bishop to G3 and
there's no better way to do it now Rook
captures on C1 Knight captures on C1 and
now H captures on G3 and okay now Queen
to F2 is coming you have to stop that so
Knight to D3 can be played now G
captures and H2
uh King to H1 or you capture then you
allow the black queen into the game with
check and now it doesn't really matter
like Knight to F4 can be played uh
whatever you play here is simply in
insufficient if Knight captures an F4
Queen captures uh okay let's play
something like Bishop to D3 to try and
defend against Checkmate uh but now even
a nice move like Bishop to F2 you
prevent the queen from uh defending
Queen to F3 check is coming and if
Bishop to F1 even a move like a bishop
to B6 attacks The Rook attacks the
bishop game over the this is unplayable
whatever you do like Queen E2 you pick
up the free rook and then you just
continue with the game but the white
king will get checkmated
um uh fairly quickly so that's what you
should should not do after Knight
captures and E4 what you should do and
by should do it's probably still gonna
cost you the game is Knight to F2 and
maybe maybe white can defend this let's
say Knight captures on F2 Bishop
captures and F2 and now Bishop captures
in C1 you even allow Queen captures and
G6 with check Rook to G7 and now where
do you go I mean you can try to defend
the B2 Pawn but if you try this let's
say Bishop to C2 then even Bishop
captures and G4 and I'll look at these
threats Bishop captures and F3 is coming
Rook captures and C7 is coming what can
you play here you can trade of course
through captress and G7 this comes with
check King captures and now Queen to C7
with check but doesn't really matter
King to G8 now you can capture on G4 but
now even Bishop captures and beat you
don't even have to rush Queen captures
and F2 Bishop captures on B2 and now
again the bishop here is hanging you
capture here Bishop captures an A3 white
is a black is of the exchange uh black
is much better here maybe white can't
survive but it's uh you know that's a
lot of moves to figure out however after
Knight captures an E4 Wesley played a
rook to D1 he just moves The Rook out of
arms away but now the position is
completely winning for Hikaru
but if Hikaru finds it one move that
actually wins the game so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this move that's why I didn't ask you to
pause the video to find that one I I
want you to find this one while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
well I I I I I I have to call it
something but I'm I will call it a
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook
characters on F3 just you know uh
completely uh crashing through the
position and now there's no way to
defend this it's uh what what do you
play if you play something like Bishop
to D2 which is the top engine move don't
ask me why uh let's see what happens
here Bishop captures on D2 Rook captures
and D7 Rook captures on D3 and now if if
Ro captures on D3 happens and uh White
is helpless here you know that you know
it's way past your your point of
resignation uh because here if of course
if the queen captures Knight to F to
check just with with a monster Royal
Fork here you resign if Bishop captures
the bishop no longer covers the F3
Square so you just get checkmated Queen
F3 checking to G1 Queen captures and G
for checking date one and Knight to F2
uh a beautiful uh
a fork Checkmate if you will so you can
do that in the game Wesley played Rook
captures on D7 but now comes Rook to F1
with check the only way to win but of
course Hikaru spots it uh you cannot
capture because Queen captures and F1
will be Checkmate so King to G2 and now
look at this bishop to E3 uh now we go
into the line that we've discussed but
here in this particular setup Hikaru had
an even uh more beautiful way to win and
I'm just gonna show it to you because
it's disgusting how beautiful it is uh
when I saw this I actually got up from
my chair and I was like what I mean what
is this what what is happening here uh
point is that H3 check is uh total
Annihilation uh King characters in H3 is
the only move and now you play Rook to
F2
I I know and now after Bishop captures
an F2 Queen captures an F2 you even
sacrifice the queen and after Knight
captures an F2 there's Knight to F4
check King the H for only move and
Bishop to G5 Checkmate I know I'm pretty
sure most of you got got up from your
chair even if you're at work watching
this I mean absolute Madness uh but okay
Hikaru Play Bishop D3 which is also
completely winning uh and now again no
defense against Rook to G1 Bishop to G3
was played and now H captors and G3 we
have Rook captures on F1 Knights the H4
check and now if you go to H1 then G2 is
Checkmate so you have to go up the board
King H3 and now Queen to H6 preparing
some very nasty discoveries so G5 was
played now comes Knight captures and G5
check King to G4 and now Knight H to F3
uh point is that if you try capturing
some material uh Queen to H3 will be
Checkmate so Wesley stops at Knight to
F2 guards the H3 square but now just
Queen to H4 check the King has to go up
the board King to F5 now rooked the f8
with check with King to G6 and now Rook
to F6 with check uh sacrificing The Rook
for a beautiful Checkmate King captures
and not Knight the E for a beautiful
double check from the Knight and the
Queen and while Wesley could go down the
board and allow mate in two knights to D
for checking G6 and now Queen to G5 he
says alright I already came to the sixth
rank I might as well remain there he
played King to G6 and Hikaru just
delivered a beautiful queen to G5
Checkmate as you've seen on the
thumbnail so that's the answer to a
question how the white king got here so
absolutely incredible you can see that
okay not just anyone I mean no one can
uh no one uh can challenge Hikaru to the
main line of the king's Indian defense
gelfand tried it in 2014 Wesley tried it
in 2015 and we've seen seen many many
games in Blitz bullet and shorter time
formats in uh you know newer years like
20 20 21 2022 uh how he covered just uh
destroys everyone here so while we are
waiting for our next brilliancy In
classical uh regarding hikaru's Kings
Indian defense uh we can enjoy these uh
great gems of the gems and games of the
past uh so yeah uh that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed that Hikaru did not win
this tournament but he got shared second
place I think with uh Magnus Carlsen
with Anish giri and with someone else
Wesley he was the wild card he got last
place in this tournament and the
tournament Was Won by none other than 11
arunian uh so yeah there we have it hope
you enjoyed it uh We've covered up a few
more lines than we do usual but it's
classical chess and I mean you've seen
the lines uh your head probably is still
hurting from from all of them so hope
you guys don't mind but yeah once again
really hope you enjoyed it uh looking
forward to the Grand Chester it starts
tomorrow the today's the opening
ceremony it's being played here in
Croatia in Zagreb I would like to thank
Federico Torres Velasco Dan McCormick
James Eugene Cashman mocosoft and Josh
Stanton for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
yeah do check out hikaru's Immortal game
first link in the description below uh
if you like this you will love that